[Music]
hey everyone welcome
to another installment of harry potter
theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing the harry potter books
the harry potter films and none other
than lord voldemort more specifically
we're going to be taking a look at
voldemort's character and uncovering
a few little-known facts about voldemort
that only book readers will know
voldemort's character and his journey
from tom riddle the orphan to the dark
lord
is certainly a riveting one with many
layers beneath the surface
unfortunately however if you only
watched the films then you will have
only been given a glimpse of voldemort's
past
in this video i'm going to be discussing
five aspects of voldemort's character
that were left out of the films
without further ado let's get into it
number five
his mother murapi used to love potion on
his father
merapi gaunt later meribee riddle was a
pure blood witch and the daughter of
marvolo gaunt
mariby grew up in little hangleton and
developed an obsession with a muggle to
live nearby
tom riddle senior who was a handsome and
wealthy man
merapi after years of abuse from her
brother and father
had very suppressed magical capabilities
however
one day her magical ability manifested
itself in the form of a love potion
that marapi used on riddle shortly after
he drank the potion
he became infatuated with merapee fast
forward just a few months later
the two were married and therapy was
pregnant with tom's child
this child would later go on to become
lord voldemort
number four he was strange right from
birth
in the half-blood prince it's first
revealed that voldemort had always been
a strange person
even in early childhood mrs cole who was
a worker at wolves orphanage where
voldemort was raised
admitted that tom exhibited some very
unusual behaviors
first of all he terrified the other
children and apparently
there was some nasty incidents involved
second of all
voldemort didn't cry even as a newborn
lying on his back in a crib
voldemort couldn't shed a tear and this
is a byproduct of how he was conceived
because his mother had given his father
a love potion
voldemort lacked the ability to feel
motions like love
i'm not sure there's any warning sign
quite like a baby that doesn't cry or
show emotion
number three he worked at borgin and
berks you might be surprised to hear
that even lord voldemort once had a job
like the rest of us well they're having
a job part at least
i'm not sure working at borgin and berks
is particularly relatable
for most of us anyway as a young lad and
recent hogwarts graduate
tom riddle traveled to nocturne alley
where the shop balkan and berks was
located
borgenenburg's is an antique shop that
has a bit of a dodgy reputation
for selling dark wizarding artifacts and
dealing with questionable witches and
wizards
so you can probably see what attracted
voldemort as it turns out
he only took the job so that he could
find out more about horcruxes
number two voldemort's hogwarts job
interview if you didn't know already
the defense against the dark arts
professor role at hogwarts is cursed
that's why no professor seems to be able
to keep the role for more than one
school year
i'm not sure if you noticed the trend of
a new data professor
in each and every book film as it turns
out the reason for this
is that voldemort himself once
interviewed for the position
but was turned down by dumbledore
voldemort wasn't openly evil yet
and to many he was still just a
promising young hogwarts graduate
but dumbledore was no slouch and knew
that riddle wanted
the role for nefarious reasons because
he was snubbed by dumbledore
riddle voldemort cursed the role so that
no one would ever be able to teach dada
for more than one year number one harry
and voldemort are related
that's right the arch rivals with such
completely opposite agendas
are actually distantly related it all
starts with the pevel brothers
the recipients of the three deathly
hallows ignotus the youngest brother
and recipient of the invisibility cloak
was actually the relative of none other
than harry potter
we know that harry receives the
invisibility cloak as a gift from his
father
but what wasn't originally revealed was
that the same cloak was passed down over
generations
starting with ignotus and as it turns
out
voldemort is a distant relative of
cadmus the brother who chose the
resurrection stone
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
[Music]
you